étant donné que c'était bloqué par des
voitures je vais pas rester dans le
milieu de la rue léonie gray a eu très
peur le 15 juillet sur le boulevard
heureusement maroua bhl qui n'en a ni
paul gervais au dessus de mon vélo puis
après ça j'ai atterri face première dans
l'entretoit
j'ai continué de glisser face première
dans le trottoir ça m'a brisé trois
dents avant ça m'a brisé le cartilage du
nez j'avais là le visage vraiment un
flamand son amoureux a même craint pour
sa vie
leoni a dû s'absenter du travail et
assumer une facture de plus de 5000 $
chez le dentiste
en plus de différents spécialistes
qu'elle doit consulter
elles réclament vingt mille dollars à la
ville comme à la ville de juges comme
ceux sécuritaire pour les cyclistes pour
les piétons pour tout le monde en
général
la chanteuse dont l'histoire suscite une
vague de soutien sur un site de
financement participatif n'est pas la
seule à dénoncer l'état de la chaussée
les nids-de-poule à vélo sur la même
chose pour les voitures sauf c'est
encore plus dangereux
c'est dingue c'était le printemps
courvelles où étaient sacrés comme un
peu une trappe allen ne se prend pas
bien à bust la toussaint dans tant
d'autres on fait attention puisque les
routes sont pas toujours bonnes sur les
pistes ou sur les autres souvent
beaucoup de mes poules
on a eu des améliorations sur le
marquage des pistes cyclables qui s'est
fait beaucoup plus rapidement cette
année que les années précédentes mais au
niveau de la qualité de la chaussée
malheureusement à vue de à vue d'oeil on
voit pas de grosses améliorations
au moment de notre tournage des cols
bleus colmater les nids de poule du
boulevard aux mans tous ont été
remblayés sauf un celui qui a causé
l'accident brioni et l'administration
municipale n'a pas souhaité commenter le
dossier indiquant qu'il est sous étude
au bureau des réclamations de la ville
ici julie mars au réseau canada montréal